how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe
yesterday it was announced that on
disney's investors day which is december
10th which is this thursday we're going
to be getting some pretty big marvel
news
and that news is the announcement of new
disney projects for both
disney plus and movies these
announcements are going to be projects
for marvel's phase 5 of the marvel
cinematic universe
so since we're about to get some pretty
big phase 5 news and new movies and
projects announced let's go over
everything that we know so far about the
upcoming projects for marvel's phase 5.
be sure to subscribe if you're new for
some awesome marvel content also so you
can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a zombie mysterio funko
pop
from deadpool 3 to the fantastic four
and x-men to the new avengers arriving
sometime in the mcu
we actually know quite a bit about the
future of marvel studios and the mcu
so i'm going to go over every confirmed
show coming to disney plus and
every confirmed movie that we know
marvel studios has in development right
now
then we'll go over some of the
unconfirmed movies and shows that have
been rumored about and have a high
probability of coming sometime soon
so let's go ahead and start with the
confirmed shows that we know are going
to be coming in marvel's phase 5.
these have already been announced
officially by marvel studios and kevin
feige
now these three shows have been
announced for quite some time now we
have marvel
she-hulk miss marvel and moon knight
right now currently miss marvel is
filming and they have cast iman valani
to play the role of kamala khan aka
miss marvel she hulk is in
pre-production and according to some
reports
tatiana menslane has been cast for the
role of jennifer walters aka
she-hulk now since then tatiana has
denied these claims but we've seen other
actors deny these claims before
only to end up actually playing the
roles that they denied they were going
to play
so there's a high chance that she
actually is going to be playing jennifer
walters and she hulk
then we have moon knight which is kind
of starting to gear up the latest
reports say that oscar isaac is
currently in negotiations with marvel
studios right now to play mark spector
aka moon knight now these three shows
coming in phase five is a really good
thing because all of these three shows
are going to introduce new characters
and while we are definitely very very
excited for marvel's phase four disney
plus shows
they are based on existing characters
wanda vision
sam and bucky hawkeye loki and of course
they'll be introducing some new side
characters as well and there's a ton of
hype and excitement around these shows
right now but phase five is going to
need some new characters which we are
getting with these three shows
now another disney plus show that has
been officially confirmed is the show
that's going to
revolve around nick fury we're not
exactly sure what the title of this
disney plus show is going to be yet but
sam jackson is confirmed to be returning
to reprise his role as nick fury
and that's it for the confirmed shows
that we have so far for marvel's phase 5
now to get on to the confirmed movies
now when it comes to a new
phase a new slate of films you have to
have sequels to films that we've seen in
previous phases
but of course they can't all be sequels
otherwise the hype
isn't exactly as big as it could be but
with the new projects that marvel has
coming there is definitely no shortage
of hype
to start it off just a couple of weeks
ago it was confirmed that
deadpool is currently in development now
ryan reynolds told us basically a year
ago
that deadpool was now over at marvel
studios and that they were working on
the film already
but now it has been officially confirmed
that marvel studios has hired the
mollino
sisters along with ryan reynolds himself
to write the new deadpool 3.
this puts it on track for a phase 5
release a recent rumor going around
states that deadpool 3 is actually going
to take place
during the events of avengers infinity
war and avengers in game and we'll see
what deadpool was up to the whole entire
time behind the scenes of what the
avengers were doing then we have
blade blade was officially announced at
2019
san diego comic-con by kevin feige of
course mahershala ali has been cast as
blade and recently marvel has hired
writers for the series as well
everyone is really excited for blade
because not only is blade an awesome
character but his movie is said to be
introducing the
monster verse to the mcu the monster
verse will include characters like
dracula the punisher doctor strange
basically the entire group of the
midnight
suns so fans are not only really excited
about the movie itself
but also the new side of the mcu that
it's going to introduce
then we have one of the projects that a
lot of people cannot wait to finally see
happen in phase 5 and that is the
fantastic
four kevin feige also announced the
fantastic four
in 2019 at san diego comic-con now as of
right now we haven't heard anything
official as far as casting is concerned
or as far as hiring writers and
directors are concerned however
there has been a ton of talk from the
fan base stating that they would love to
have
john krasinski playing mr fantastic reed
richards
and his wife in real life emily blunt to
play sue storm
slash the invisible woman now a lot of
people think that these two would be
perfect for these specific roles and
what's really interesting is
many people have said for a while that
disney and marvel doesn't listen to fan
casts
however it was recently revealed that
rosario dawson who plays ahsoka in the
mandalorian
was chosen for the role because of the
fan cast now of course she looked the
part and in the episode that she's been
in she played the part really really
well
in fact it was probably a perfect
casting so this means that marvel
studios and disney are definitely open
to at least considering john krasinski
for the role of mr fantastic and his
wife emily blunt for the role of the
invisible woman
not to mention there are also reports
that john krasinski did recently meet
with marvel studios and we know for a
fact that his wife
did meet with marvel studios as well
while she was filming jungle cruise
which is also a disney film
so they could actually get the roles and
we should be finding out sometime soon
since the fantastic four
isn't that far away now kevin feige also
didn't mention
mutants aka the x-men at san diego
comic-con in 2019 as well
however based off of everything that
we've heard we shouldn't be expecting an
x-men film in phase 5. but just because
we aren't getting a movie in phase 5
doesn't mean that some of the x-men
aren't going to appear
because there will definitely be some
mutants in phase 4 and in phase 5 as
well
and then of course we have the sequels
that are confirmed guardians of the
galaxy vol 3
captain marvel 2 and ant-man 3 or as
some people are calling it ant-man and
the wasp
too and then of course black panther 2
which we thought would definitely be
delayed but according to some reports
black panther 2 is going to start
filming the middle of next
year so we're going to have to wait and
see about that one now as far as
unconfirmed movies are concerned we are
expected to get
a new avengers film sometime in phase 5.
this movie isn't necessarily going to be
a huge infinity war or in-game level
event but simply another normal avengers
film with a new avengers team
the team will consist of some of the old
characters and new characters from
marvel space 4
and phase 5. now the next project is
unconfirmed on whether or not it's going
to be a movie or a disney plus show and
it's unconfirmed on whether or not it's
coming in phase 5 or the next phase but
it's definitely a project that people
have been reporting about and a project
that a lot of people are very excited
about
and that is the young avengers now a lot
of the young avengers team
has already been introduced in the mcu
or is going to be introduced in phase 4.
we have harley keener who could be an
iron lad who was introduced in iron man
2 and we saw again at tony stark's
funeral in avengers in game
we have cassie lang the daughter of
scott lang aka ant-man who would go on
to play
stature we have kate bishop who's going
to take on the manta lopakai and now
it's been officially confirmed that
haley steinfeld will be indeed playing
kate bishop in the mcu we of course have
miss marvel who is going to be coming in
phase 5
and wanda envisions twin boys wiccan and
speed who are going to be coming in
phase 4 in the one division show
so the lineup for the young avengers is
already set the only question now is
when exactly are all of these characters
going to come together and when exactly
are we going to be getting the actual
young avengers team and as far as
official news about phase 5 goes that's
pretty much all we know right now but
hopefully in just a couple of days we'll
be getting a lot more information about
what to expect
and again according to the report they
are supposed to reveal actual projects
both
movies and disney plus shows so based
off of everything that we know right now
let me know in the comments down below
which project you are most excited for
in phase 5. don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all of the latest mcu news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
me